there we go it started before Dawn
Ukraine woke to explosions around the
capital Kiev
it was the same across the country
these pictures from kharkif in the east
enormous blouse also in the city of
donipro
[Music]
Sirens bled out across the capital
Above the Clouds of fighter jet soared
over our heads Russian or Ukrainian we
don't know which
this was to be a day of targeted attacks
by the Russian forces
that never tries to hinder us and even
more so to create threats to our country
to our people should know that Russia's
response will be immediate and it will
lead you to such consequences that you
have never encountered in your history
shocked Witnesses filmed this video of
missiles hitting the Ivano Frankie
airport in the country's West
foreign
Russia appeared to be targeting
essential infrastructure helicopter
gunships hovering above a power plant
other power stations were targeted as
well
including the Chernobyl nuclear power
station raising fears of an even greater
disaster
Ukraine's president held an emergency
meeting with his top staff pledging the
fight will go on
what ukrainians should do help the
National Defense join the National Armed
Forces territorial defense anyone with
experience in the Army it's really
important and we will not let the enemy
go any further on our territory
Russian armored personnel carriers and
other military vehicles cross the border
from Belarus into Ukraine as President
Putin's forces attempted to take control
[Music]
military trucks also seen heading north
from Crimea annexed in 2014.
and tanks rolled through the cities
including Sumi heralding a new phase in
this escalating crisis we now have war
in Europe on a scale and of an overtype
with thought belonged to history NATO
allies condemn Russia's invasion of
Ukraine in the strongest possible terms
it is a blatant violation of
international law
in the capital streets usually teeming
with people became quiet not deserted
but fundamentally different to just 24
hours earlier
within hours it was clear a mass Exodus
had started this man and his family told
us they'd tried to get it onto a train
heading west
you said he was giving up though from
going home without a car you're stuck he
told me
foreign
heading out of Kiev was suddenly jammed
with traffic
miles and miles of queues
people getting out of buses for a break
before continuing on
these women said they and everyone on
the bus was heading to the West maybe
then onto Poland and safety well for
weeks now people have been telling us
that nothing's going to happen that
they're going to stay in Kiev they're
going to stay in their homes but it has
happened and this is the effect it's a
log Jam here this is the main road to
Western Ukraine as you can see
we're in a massive massive parking lot
now
cues began to form outside petrol
stations and then at Banks and cash
machines people withdrawing their
savings and attempting to head away from
the Russian forces there has been plenty
of defiance in Ukraine in recent days
on the street a few Hardy Souls came out
to support the nation
the flag carried with pride
but in the face of the Russian army
there's not much more that they can do
Stu Ramsey Sky News Kiev